okay  so  Vietnam is a favorite yeah and uh offer  skill is winning  okay seems like because Monmouth is  completely winning uh  he's not completely winning he just won  his game my name is Carson  G5 I guess yeah he had seen enough uh  yeah Rook H6 Rook H6 and then mate yeah  yeah  so you breaking you you break through  and you win well what to say after such  a game I mean he played so bizarre in  the opening yeah and he just wins with  the left hand I mean that's  amazing don't try to do the same because  so yeah  yeah because uh well uh this can really  backfire so yeah so for today our first  pill is actually having a very good day  Magnus has already won uh